me walking down the street being so good
to me yeah yeah holding hands being
together like friendships we doing it
real me walking down the street being so
good to me yeah yeah feeling good with
the butterflies in the skies and me
happy on the trail with my friends
feeling good feeling good feeling good
feeling good feeling welcome to another
episode of of tiger belly TB to be tiger
belly I am your captain not a messiah
but a prophet for sure
one of the I have a kingdom the tiger
belly Kingdom there are many kingdoms in
the podcast world you have steel Vaughn
as a kingdom and sometimes we grace his
stages and he comes to our kingdom and
he comes into the castle and we we talk
and we rant and we have good times
fat Eric Griffin has sometimes has a
kingdom he's black and fat and doing his
thing with the glasses you know me and
living like a [ __ ] mutant warrior the
way he is you know me with his black
titties and then we also got oh we also
got a segura and his wife Christina
punkah mainstay come they come right we
sometimes go to their Kingdom but
there's another Kingdom a mysterious
island
out there it's at the island of it's an
Italian island Taliah where they tall
and they're a [ __ ] strong force but I
don't want to get into that yet I want
to reintroduce everyone in the room and
we've got George Kimmel you know when I
sing that song I think of you oh thank
you
we got Gilbert Kalani on yep I love it
you have forehead for years
thank you have to come you know your
forehead
like the Sahara Desert I want to walk on
it forever and thank you so much you're
welcome
we got uncle I like you my beautiful
sidekick my partner in life my woman and
my friend and my life partner forgot his
name Jason Jason Witt Jason you know
thin lips legs legs legs for days
because lips arts just like razor thin
the way it's supposed to be the way God
made it I finally got to see venom
what's the whole plot of the film I see
not to talk until I did you do I got to
see venom yep who's in it Tom Hardy all
right all right all right fine okay fine
do it I'm gonna do it all right so um
I'm gonna just read you some tweets no I
mean no no I already write a message
between you and me I mean the messages
okay so I say this is what daliyah Chris
D'Elia
okay I'm close but this [ __ ] dumbass
traffic [ __ ] this area I go relax
don't worry don't tell me to relax
I'll flip he says I said calm down and
this is what this [ __ ] guy says and
what a spread of fruit out for me when I
arrived pretzels etc and I said okay
here [ __ ] which one I give him the
address
okay here I said George is coming down
he goes I'm [ __ ] waiting yeah and the
reason why he acts like that is because
he is a king of his own Island at
daliyah Island and Matt D'Elia bill
D'Elia they all live there and they have
a kingdom and they're very powerful and
he has a Netflix special out right now
on Netflix Yeah right
yeah what my show on Netflix yeah yeah
yeah what's a call called non-stop Ron
stop to believe it right let me know
that it's all right all right you
understand
it's closed oh my god you sing my
favorite [ __ ] song right away
I want to sing too and you're [ __ ]
done I'm waiting he says don't talk and
you're [ __ ] it yes
come on do not try to teach you things
all right right to be patient right Rara
because you were so impatient
during the text you're right so you got
to be more patient okay we have a friend
of mine he's a king I'm Sir Christopher
D'Elia everybody give him her on a ride
thank you
welcome welcome King sir do you know
what the [ __ ] when you started
singing I was like I wanted to sing so
bad no I was like I thought you were
[ __ ] with you you're like well Chris is
gonna come in yeah they tell him not to
talk until I introduce himself introduce
him which is what he did and then he's
like watch I guarantee he chimes in with
the song you did this song and that's
you know that's my favorite I wanna
[ __ ] I wanted I want to hate but I
like that song like you gonna nurse and
there's so many [ __ ] people in this
and there's still too many people in
this you know you have a guy in the
closet last time yeah Jason it's always
it's always a different guy yeah yeah
you just pick up rant random dudes and
no way cept if some people are busy you
know and you can see like I learned his
lesson yeah [ __ ] come on the clown I
asked you a question
I'm circus Taliah all right why are your
bags and your eyes do not sleep good
last night I no no you know what it's
the [ __ ] lighting probably but also
had a bags under my eyes
[ __ ] Prada - it is Prada Gucci look
man I got Gucci I got pride I got bags
but it's all good I'm grizzled man I got
the [ __ ] [ __ ] coming out I got pepper
so I'm pepper coming in yeah yeah yeah
do do you want from me I know you're
[ __ ] all amazed hold drink of water
and I got Paxson right yeah but can I
say something it's up you're handsome
thank you that's a good thing yeah I
think you're artistic
okay very creative thank you right and
you are who you are thank you and that's
a compliment those are three really good
comment those are very good complement
and can I say this right now okay um
drop the attitude you know what dude
yeah yeah I'm being real right yeah I
know you are I know could I just see
this so all right okay I love you thank
you let me see what
know what you're like [ __ ] Stalin bro
people can just talk I know you could
just say you know what I said when I
already be real go ahead how many times
he's already told me not to talk twice
I'm a [ __ ] guest on he's got their
pocket I know but why say as much as you
want okay is is that um I honestly when
I see you I I realize the foundation
that we built our friendship is
rock-solid
yeah and you haven't changed even from
the beginning you're the same you and I
appreciate that you you know people have
this you know your star you are now a
comedy star and that's real that is real
but the thing is is that you haven't
drifted away from who you are and you're
a good dude with a good foundation and
I'm so glad to know you and I love you
so [ __ ] much because I want to say
this is that um we asked a couple of
people to do this up episode right and
you came through for me
[ __ ] yeah yeah because you're I know
you're at Facebook guys right now
but no yeah you do you do all right
they're bags I got I like the little
white in your face you know that's good
but I Love You Man and so thank give
them run okay that's to run of applause
[Music]